[Music]
in a year where comic book movies are
starting to fade no one wants to see
dramas and our most beloved celebrities
can't get people into theaters Hollywood
has decided to repurpose the same 19th
century public domain Italian novel
three different times in one calendar
year with let's say varying results
I can't wait to go to school and learn
what all this stuff is I don't want to
be one of a kind
I want to be like everyone else
every 2022 Pinocchio movie
four generations audiences fell in love
with Pinocchio a puppet who learns to be
honest and Brave on his way to becoming
a real boy but what if that wasn't the
true story and it was really a crime
drama about a gang of Thieves
infiltrating a circus I'll tell the
whole truth about what you're really
doing and then every one of you will go
to jail where the Blue Fairy was
actually the Scarlet Witch Jiminy
Cricket was a horse with weird put Downs
I find his appearance rather dull you
could have made a more joyful and
intelligent puppet and Pinocchio was a
gasified horse dancer
[Music]
[Applause]
why because it's made in Russia the only
thing they love more than horse dancing
is dash cam videos kids movies are just
built different over there I will whip
you to death no
I will kill you too with my bare hands
experience a film that looks almost as
good as a freemium mobile game ad
with an All-Star cast of the best voice
Talent currently on Cameo the M like 90s
icon Pauly Shore he's a little Jew oofs
who transforms his voice chameleon-like
into that of 90s icon Pauly Shore
a boy and I'm alive when can I leave to
be on my own I want to meet other people
it's just me
Napoleon Dynamite's John hater who
actually Alters his voice probably out
of embarrassment
I knew it all along and SpongeBob Legend
Tom Kenny as Geppetto who really has
nothing to be embarrassed about I mean
it's not like he was the voice of skids
in Transformers 2. oh that that's old
school yo that that's like that's the
sabatonian wait he was ah Barnacles so
if you're looking for a take on
Pinocchio that's a little bit different
than what you're used to enjoy the only
version where his dad is a horse you
want me to be your father just say yes I
promise I'll be a good son he gets third
hand directions from three different
clowns one of the clowns I know was told
by another clown but there is a fairy
who lives by a mountain and everyone is
strapped at all times let me make a
couple holes in this puppet
I'll be my ticket out of here
I say enough with the shooting already
but hey at least the songs are also in
the movie
we've been deceived as well and
monziofoco is their boss
NP no man
from director Robert zemekis who's moved
full time into The Uncanny Valley comes
a movie so aware of its own crappiness
they basically rub your face in it in a
film destined to slide quietly down the
end of a Disney plus Sub menu where it
will slowly run away into the obscurity
it so richly deserves and not just an
accent an entrepreneur nay an influencer
no turn on Disney plus best argument for
adding a playback speed option in a film
that's only worth watching to check in
on how many holes long covid has put
into Tom Hanks brain why because he
likes you
as he turns Geppetto into the biggest
2022 boy lover since his take on the
colonel now turn around let me get a
look at you oh very handsome
hey my boy my boy bumbling around a
green screened hellscape singing
Nonsense to nobody
smoked holy Smoky Oh indeed can you
believe Chet Hanks had a better year
than his dad big up the whole island
massive it's her boy
so prepare for a Pinocchio that's bad in
all the most boring ways I have some
very good garments foreign with the same
beats as the original with all the edges
sanded off
full of wink nudge comedy that's out of
date before the movie even came out we
need a stage name Chris Pine nah it'd
never work Timeless an animation that
looks like you told an AI about a wooden
boy then pulled the plug before it
finished rendering at least when wah put
his animators in the Sweatshop they made
Cinderella modernity socks Forrest stump
from anti-carnival activist Guillermo
del Toro comes a story he's been
passionate about making for so long cute
swear it featured a child in World War
II sympathetic monsters evil humans and
a sea creature that someone tries to
have sex with no well four out of five
ain't bad put the kids to bed for a
Pinocchio story that truly considers the
implications of being a soulless piece
of wood that will never take the place
of a sad old man's murdered child that
makes our childlike hero die repeatedly
you will die many many times
swaps Pleasure Island for a fascist
Military Academy and ends with him
bearing the only people he ever loved
that's so relentlessly Grim all the best
jokes are about Nazi salutes gone wrong
[Music]
seek hilarious so if you want to watch
the one 2022 Pinocchio movie that was
actually good thanks to the always great
gdt and a co-director who's done
claymation for so long he worked on the
California Raisins watch the war that
was beautifully crafted with a
Bittersweet message about retaining your
humanity and a standout performance from
Kristoff Waltz as a circus freak who
spanks his monkey you have any idea
nobody wanted
Kristoff Watson fascist Europeans seem a
better combo morning wood
not starring these other Pinocchio
adaptations because wow the pee hole
goes deep the 70 Soviet versions the TV
miniseries with Bob Hoskins that just
made Pinocchio real boy the whole time
to cut costs the one where Seinfeld
crosses over with The Drew Carey Show
the most 90s version possible the most
2000s version possible the one where an
adult man plays Pinocchio the one where
the same adult man now plays Geppetto
but Pinocchio is somehow even creepier
the up-and-coming dark and gritty video
game the one with James Spader and
strings but now I'm free
and the Shrek version which probably
wins by default I
am are you
like you most certainly am off
every 2022 Pinocchio movie
when somebody calls themselves honest
they ain't oh no they're on to us quick
everyone scram
ble Merry Christmas
us
now bring us some piggy pudding and
bring it out here you are on my naughty
list you've heard of Elf on the Shelf
now get ready for honest trailers on oh
forget it this will never get red